you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with lymphoma
this video will help you understand some
of the available treatment options
lymphoma is a cancer that begins in your
lymphatic system
in the lymphatic tissue lymphoma
originates in certain types of white
blood cells called lymphocytes
in lymphoma the lymphocytes become
abnormal and multiply to make too many
abnormal cells that don't work properly
the two main types of lymphoma are
hodgkin lymphoma and non-hodgkin
lymphoma
your doctor will make a treatment plan
specifically for your lymphoma
it will be based on the type of lymphoma
the stage your symptoms
age
overall health and other factors
treatment options may include one or
more of the following
chemotherapy
radiation therapy
targeted therapy
immunotherapy
and stem cell transplant
chemotherapy is usually injected into a
vein under the skin
or taken as a pill orally
the chemotherapy then enters the
bloodstream to reach and destroy cancer
cells another treatment option is
radiation therapy it uses high energy
rays to kill cancer cells or stop them
from growing the target area of the
radiation varies depending on the stage
and type of lymphoma
the type of radiation therapy used for
lymphoma is external beam radiation it
uses a machine that aims carefully
focused beams of radiation at the cancer
from outside of the body
targeted therapy drugs act on specific
targets or markers on cancer cells
since cancer cells may have more of
these markers than normal cells do
targeted therapy drugs may affect cancer
cells more than normal cells
when targeted therapy drugs attached to
the markers on cancer cells the cancer
cells may stop growing and dividing
it can also lead to cell death
immunotherapy can help your immune
system fight lymphoma for example
monoclonal antibodies are
laboratory-made versions of proteins
that the immune system makes to help
fight infections
monoclonal antibodies can be designed to
attack specific targets such as markers
on lymphoma cells
when attached to immune cells monoclonal
antibodies can help recognize and
destroy the lymphoma cells
a stem cell transplant replaces
blood-forming stem cells that were
damaged or destroyed during your cancer
treatment with either your or a healthy
donor's stem cells first healthy stem
cells are collected from you or a donor
then the stem cells are stored while you
receive treatment for cancer such as
chemotherapy or radiation to try to kill
all your blood cells
after these treatments are complete the
healthy stem cells are put into your
blood through an intravenous line or iv
in your body these blood-forming stem
cells provide a healthy supply of future
blood cells
your doctor may prescribe a combination
of the treatments we've discussed or
different treatment options than those
mentioned here
as you deal with a diagnosis of lymphoma
continue to talk to your doctor and your
cancer care team
you